حسنًا، من المؤكد أن الأوكرانيين يدركون
بعض الشكوك في
الولايات المتحدة بشأن تمويل أوكرانيا،
خاصة فيما يتعلق بالأسلحة،
ولكن أيضًا بالطبع فيما
يتعلق بالمال، وكذلك بين
الجمهوريين في الكونجرس وأيضًا
بين الجمهور الأمريكي الآن.  كان فلاديمير
زيلينسكي، رئيس البلاد،
بالطبع في الآونة الأخيرة في
الولايات المتحدة وكان يطلب المزيد من
الأسلحة لأن الأوكرانيين
يفهمون أنهم إذا كانوا سيبقون
في القتال ضد الروس
ويحرزون تقدمًا ضد الروس فسوف يفعلون ذلك.
بحاجة إلى الكثير من الأسلحة الآن،
هناك بعض العناصر التي
قال الأوكرانيون إنها ستكون
أساسية لهم في المستقبل، على سبيل المثال،
الصواريخ المهاجمة هي بالتأكيد
شيء يريدونه وبالطبع
في المستقبل أيضًا طائرات F-16 لإعادة
بناء قوتهم الجوية بشكل أساسي  وفقًا
لمعايير حلف شمال الأطلسي، فإنهم يعتقدون أيضًا أن هذه
الطائرات أكثر قدرة بكثير من
تلك التي تطير بها الآن، لكن
على المدى القصير، يقول الأوكرانيون إنها
الذخيرة التي يحتاجون إليها حقًا،
وهم بالتأكيد بحاجة إلى الكثير منها
وأحدها.  الأشياء المثيرة للاهتمام التي
حرص فلاديمير زلينسكي على القيام بها هي القول،
انظر، لقد كان هناك بعض الحديث عن
الفساد المحتمل داخل
وزارة الدفاع هنا في أوكرانيا، وقال إنه
لا يوجد شيء له علاقة
بالأسلحة التي قدمتها
الولايات المتحدة و  أحد الأشياء
التي قام بها أيضًا بالطبع هو أنه استبدل
وزير دفاعه
قبل مجيئه إلى الولايات المتحدة وأخذ
وزير الدفاع الجديد إلى
الولايات المتحدة لطمأنة الولايات المتحدة بأنها إذا
أعطت أسلحة ومتى تعطي أسلحة
لأوكرانيا  ستكون
عملية شفافة، حيث يدرك الأوكرانيون تمامًا
أنه بدون المزيد من الأسلحة من
الولايات المتحدة وشركائها أيضًا،
سيواجهون وقتًا صعبًا للغاية في
الحفاظ على بعض العمليات رفيعة المستوى
التي يقومون بها
الآن.  شرق أوكرانيا،
تمسك الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين بنصه المعتاد بينما
احتفلت روسيا بمرور عام على إعلان
ضم أربع مناطق محتلة في
أوكرانيا، وخاطب الأمة في هذا
الفيديو الذي صدر يوم الجمعة مدعيا مرة
أخرى أن الضم يعكس
إرادة الشعب وامتثل له.  مع
المعايير الدولية، لا يعتبر أي من هذه
الأمور صحيحًا بالطبع، ادعى السيد بوتين أيضًا
أن الناس في تلك المناطق
وقفوا في كلماته في وجه القمع، وكانت هناك
محاولات لإخافتهم،
وتجريدهم من الحق في تقرير
مستقبلهم، ومصيرهم، وسلب الأشياء
التي  عزيزة على كل شخص، الثقافة،
التقاليد، اللغة الأم، كل الأشياء
التي كان يكرهها القوميون
ورعاتهم الغربيون الذين نظموا
انقلابًا في كيث في عام 2014. لقد
دعم شعب روسيا الاختيار الحر الذي لا لبس فيه
لإخواننا وأخواتنا
بكل إخلاص.
هذا وشعرنا بعمق بالشيء الرئيسي
من خلال حماية مواطنينا ودون باس
ونوفوراسيا، نحن نحمي روسيا
نفسها، نحن نقاتل معًا من أجل
الوطن الأم، سيادتنا،
القيم الروحية والوحدة من أجل انتصارنا